hello everyone welcome
to the press room of the
european commission and thank you for also following us
live online and on your
bicycle ait today wednesday october 20
at the
[Music]
presidency of the
coacher des ipad itunes match  too quickly
understood etihad airways president
michèle de somer which takes place three
inopportune trials and it is necessary to read us open
institutions switch and ride
as
too long sustainable cave is
worn in more and bass to johns
participants our freedom in hauterive
successful lighting and the refinery
and roll  and
finally allow me to
remind you that we are not going to have
meetings from noon
tomorrow because of the European side whose
work will start tomorrow during the
day and with these if we can
go to your questions in the
press room and  online so thank you for
letting me know one the winds your
hand said fits online i'm giving back my
garage renault
[Music]
is
canceled
each
[Music]
show is a follower of noah or five
chances affected the sector so 2,500
domains program for iran and for it
exact economy of voting points open
calm with
fc
basel we have to take  an attitude
like a beast or dio because of the
united states your cam to die
we had quite a shock of heroes benefit
from form of
video sharing with enrico from
trial of
foreign ministers swing dit yes you is
looking into
the
china sunergy
d  'international ford focus having been
branded content
in paris
ifran kahn benefit from over into
lifting by
[Music]
saint-philippe I see you removing it so
keep lifting if your question is
indeed for twitter
I understand that this is the case so
go ahead net more
I understand that you have to change your
audio source because
sorry yes so indeed
it's since we've been talking about dissipating yeah I'm taking this
opportunity to ask peter
if the what he said to himself  Monday in
luxembourg to know that these rumors
of a preparatory technical meeting
to heat up the negotiations which
could have taken place this week in
brussels is still out of
da embarrassment and if this is the case what
stage we can consider at
from today thank you
as the representative said already on
Monday there is no meeting
confirmed in these moments between
the european union and the ranks I can
only underline the urgency to
return to come a stop  start
the negotiations taking place in vienna
between the parties to the nuclear agreement
[Music]
10/06/2010
specific
and
nothing
but beauty is made up of a body
is it in energy is it closed it's just
because quite a few marsha  wang salford
cast of
my soul in the next three four years
want
to visit places
program
so
[Music]
economic what i didn't want to occupy screening
of paris in france for many
birds
i
lived it
michaud  of transition facebakers he
fires on next three
days of our to change everything okay
but cause the reading because this style matches
like
manager 10 of 14 inches in touch screen
an economy of
truth the 14 or 16 weeds the deep soul
hip hop and  funk argana at
[Music]
1:08 p.m. collective les
all
we can be
there is no 2 to provide the power to do
with it up
[Music]
all
our compliments to
magnard editions
not only thing by rousseau economic
olli rehn
but continues its margins and
compassion
thank you bernard
david four stages of the radical
i think i will try to
pursue tomaso's question which
seems quite relevant to me because the
social climate fund is the message that
you are sending even this morning the
president in strasbourg it is we must
protect the  more vulnerable
then I would like to know that they are
for you the most vulnerable because
we are seeing a
price increase which does not affect who
obviously affects the pl  vulnerable people who are
subject to energy poverty but not
only there is also the middle class
and when the middle class sees its
electricity or gas bill go from
1500 euros per year to 3000 euros per year it
becomes poor and you risk  to
lose the support of the middle class
for the green deal project that's the
question I think the amazon site is
asking the most venerable chickens knows
who it is
the people who are classified as
poor where it is today  today also the
middle class thank you thank you very much
david for for the question and for
broadening the debates effectively
politically and from the point of view of
all the possible impacts what I
can say clearly and that we are
determined that we are
convinced that the  transition we have
embarked on is the right thing to do and
the fossil fuel energy market and price developments
that have taken place of late are
compelling arguments.  to tell us
we must continue and even accelerate the
green transition that we have announced
we must give priority we must increase the
share of renewable energies in
our and the mix at European level
so I think that's what we've
had lately  are additional arguments
that support us, which reinforces the choice that
we have made collectively at the level
of the European Union on the transition
now beats, we have always known
that we had
to provide our support to those who
could be  concerned by this
transition it is obviously not about
what you asked for a definition or the
solution there how we see the
category of people who would
need support you
yourself mentioned energy poverty it is
clearly  the first category that
we have in view who could be
affected and who are already affected
before the ecological transition begins,
we have a category of millions
of Europeans who  i was already suffering from
energy poverty and struggling to
pay their electricity bills and
for heating at the end of the month
so the armance them it's this category
there it's the groups that will have all
our  attention at European level and
which will need support
are developments in the situation
which is now being affected by
energy prices which have as we
have been discussing for months which have
multiple causes and which are not
linked to the european green deal that
we launched this is not the cause of the
green deal europe 1 we have analyzed
the price structure extensively
what causes what constitutes the
prices of electricity the prices of
energy and that
the market situation that may have
led to the situation that we are
experiencing that we hoped are
now we have to remain
vigilant and agile to see what
how price developments in the
markets
affect  tera additional categories
because there are two things
that are clear the energy transition
will have to continue
to accelerate me but secondly it
will succeed and it will have the support of the
population obviously
insofar as we can ensure  that
everyone can benefit can
benefit
from the social and societal goods that this
transition will bring so we will
be vigilant to see how
the evolution of markets and prices will
affect other possible categories
to the logic it has all the tools
i  I will just maybe add financial support
to one that comes from several
budgetary instruments, in particular from
the European and national object of the richard
kahui project on to claim it of
overheating in common, of which we have spoken, the
jazz transition' bland so it's not
only  words ideas legislative projects
there is an investment of
rias from the European budget and that too
blocks of investment at the level
national private sector also so
obviously there are changes that are
going to come and we are very very aware
of the fact that we need a transition that
is fair who who who helps
citizens of tulle is
the societal brilliance to make the transition
to
the  to support it
yes in fact on the same subject but
other this subject if I can in relation
to the speech this morning by the president
I saw
that he very clearly expressed his support
for gas as a
transition energy
did not mention  nuclear is
this to be interpreted as an
indication of what you are going to propose
on the second phase of the taxonomy
thanks david no this should not be
interpreted as having a
direct link to the taxonomy or other
package proposals that  who could
come to see our position on the
taxonomy we would simply have to
wait for the moment when we make our
proposals I would benefit from nothing to
give more elements if ever there is no
there are no more other questions for
any topic about energy
i see there is a
camel question so i'm taking
the 100000 question boxes first and
then i would like ariana to
resume the debate on  the taxonomy its
millstone
yes hello it's in this question
of the price of gas dallas you just said
that the commission had looked
into the functioning of the market and I
wanted to know if conclusion was that
we really have to take into account  the
problem of the indexation of the
private tariff on the wholesale market price
and will come out of it we cannot question that
in order to help
consumers not to have
bills that are too high
yes I think that on this we were
quite clear in
last week's communication we will kill that
the market in terms of visits
and energy functions well has served us well for the
last twenty years
but we have requested that
from the regulatory regulators agency
European lator has made an analysis
on this subject to see if it is
also useful for him for the future for the changes
the evolution of the energy market and
will already present to us a first let's
analyze mid November
and then at the beginning of next year
an analysis  more in-depth and
recommendations also has things for
you to have on this but for
the moment an encore and that's
all we can say to Mr. that the state
of the market
thank you very much team is there any  other
questions about the energy that would be
possible I look on line I see that
rhein has a question but it's more
for ariana so it fits well with my
intention to call for nothing ensures that
the podiums so thank you steam and  arianna
to you so we will first complete the
answer on the taxonomy
following david's question
hello so what i was able to say about the
taxonomy 68th position on nuclear
in the sep taxonomy is that
the inclusion of the  nuclear in the
relative regulation  to the economy has been
the subject of intense discussion
whether nuclear energy is
systematically recognized as its
low-carbon energies
opinions differ in particular on
the potential impact on other
environmental objectives
such as  environmental assessment of
nuclear waste
the commission believes that credibility
the situation is crucial it has commissioned
a study
to assess this whole aspect a technical report this
is a very important step in the process
the jaï reports are now
examined by experts and
they  are in the process of being published they have
been published on the
commission's website
the commission will present
the conclusions of the report to the greeks
examinations carried out by the experts as in
accordance with the communication of the
commission published in April 2021 the
commission will hold
32 the  available elements and the
points of view of the parties
as provided for in the program of the
regulatory work s e  st a stage we
are thinking about the advisability of
how to deal with nuclear energy
in the regulatory framework
for sustainable finance so we are
analyzing it and evaluating it
if you can
nothing is there  other questions on
taxonomy
words extremely
[Music]
tenuous mines
or
yes i have a question
on iphone cases in jinan m this
is right now discussing
long european parliament and
i realize when there  when the
commission is going to publish
its proposal
for these guidelines
and
I also have a question do the
parliament and the council also have a
say in that or is that or only in the
european commission which decides
and at the same time yes
two questions when are we going to
publish these guidelines and the taxonomy
also is this the second
telegate idec is this going to be
published also this year again
thank you for your questions now
so I start with gal lenze  the
commission is  in the process of
evaluating good for the revision of the and
the two guidelines on
state aid in the fields
of energy and the environment
in this context it has been put out to
public consultation has targeted
have the opinion  from all the
interested parties that they presented their
opinions and observations on the
draft framework for state aid in
favor of the climate, energy and
the environment
that has been proposed in order to adapt
the schemes of  readers to others
aim to pursue pursued to
speak green bio therefore we have proposed a
number of modifications to
the current rules in particular we have a wide
of the legends applications of
guidelines in order to allow support
in the new field as well such as
clean mobility  the
energy efficiency of buildings
circularity biodiversity as well as all the
technologies likely to
implement the green deal the rules
will also define the  next to follow to
achieve the phasing out of
fossil fuels in particular
fuel as far as possible so the deadline
for interested parties to
submit their comments was
it has expired
12the 12 doubt and we are in the process
of evaluating all  the contributions received
and to take into account the opinion of the
interested parties in the revision of
the guideline and the adoption is
planned for the end of this year so
for the end of 2021
on the process that I can say in
general  on the guideline is
that the treaty whose possibility for the
commission to adopt the guidelines
of our proposal
is the guideline it is
important in general for
state aid to remember that it is
something that are in binding that they have
avoided efficiency
they are in the country against us
forcing thank you they are
binding for the commission so these
are the criteria that will be
applied in the evaluation  we have certain
state aid measures so it
's something that applies to us but
as I say clearly it's a
process that takes time because
we consult all the interested parties
and that's why  we are in
public consultation ensures the
proposal acquired which had made it a
port for the rules
it concerns the timing for the
taxonomy I think that has answered so
we know that we have no precision at
this stage to provide on the  moment when
we are ready with with his 6 I think
that there is an intricacy of the follow
-ups go ahead
m is what
ken williams is
ok to be clear is that the
commission will propose the guidelines and
can the parliament  exchange it
or intervene
or the advice no I say 1 in general
for the guidelines on
state aid it is the commission
which adopts it because therefore the municipality the
state aid of these idiots but just for
s  'explain the intestines and are not
allowed in  the european union
because they elect have negative effects
on competition there are cases in
which the positive effects
of state aid are greater than the
negative effects and it is for this
reason that the member states  can
notify the commission of the
state aid measures and the commission
can approve them we have the
regulation therefore 95% of the measure and its